[Music]
on the outskirts of a Bechet in eastern
shared they pray for peace avishay is
anwar died one of three regions where
president dotrice Derby's declared a
state of emergency after dozens of
people were killed and fighting over
land and resources between farmers and
nomadic herders the armies being
deployed to try to prevent further
unrest and security forces have made
dozens of arrests at seizing weapons
from civilians you are enforcing the
state of emergency measures and within a
very short space of time managed to
seize all of these weapons I thank you
very much and urge you to continue until
there are zero weapons in civilian hands
that's left people in this village
feeling anxious and unsafe the six
rifles we once had were seized by the
army we're now left defenseless if our
adversary's approach we had no
alternative but to report it to the
government but if the government fails
to help us our enemies will destroy us
simply because we have no weapons the
emergency measures allow authorities to
impose curfews and search homes the
president's also closed some borders
blaming the surge of unrest on conflicts
in neighboring Libya Sudan and Central
African Republic but there's concern the
border closures could stop supplies
being brought in to a nation where more
than half a million people already
struggle to get enough food Abdul Rahim
survived one of the attacks and waar
died in which several people were killed
he usually works as a driver during the
night and says the curfew isn't helping
business the whole street is closed
there's nobody we the drivers can only
get money at night during the day
there's very few people the tension
extends beyond these provinces just this
week eleven people were killed in
fighting in a dispute between herders
and farmers over trampled crops and
southern Chad the states of emergency is
said to remain in place for another ten
days but some fear the measures and
enough to end the violence
this woman's relying on prayer to
protect her community
alexia Brian al-jazeera